abone ol
[Müzik]
e
herkese merhaba Ben bugün burada
olabilme M girişimcilik hikayemi
borçluyum o Umarım siz de benim
girişimcilik hikayemden kendinize
alınması gereken dersleri alabilirsiniz
benim girişimcilik Hikayem Ben daha
henüz çok küçükken ilkokuldayken Ailemin
bana bir mikroskop hediye etmesiyle
başladı Aslında pozitif bilimleri olan
ilgi mikroskobunda olmasıyla daha da
fevkalâde bir hal almıştı ardından orta
okula geçtiğimde Sen bilgisi öğretmenim
de bunu gözlemlemiş olacak ki bana
üniversitelerde eğitim verilirken
kullanılan lisel kitabını hediye etti bu
kitabı almak başta beni çok onu ve etse
de aslında ilk tamamın sebep oldu bu
kitap hem İngilizceyle hem de içindeki
hücre görüntüleri Maalesef benim kendi
mikroskobu bu görüntüleyebileceğiniz
Yüce görüntüleri değildi bir takım hayal
kırıklığına uğramış oldum aslında tam
olarak adını koymamış olsamda daha o
yıllarda
hayatımda ve kariyerim ile ilgili
hedeflerimi belirlemeye başlamıştım
yapamazsın tercih etme o bölümü
bitirirsen Piyasada iş bulamazsın
dedikleri genetik ve biyomühendislik
bölümünü tercih ettim şimdi hem okurken
hem de hayatın içinde yaşarken hem
öğrendim hem de çok zorlandım bir tek
ülkemizde değil dünyada yapılan
çalışmaları mükemmel bir merak
duyuyordum bu merakım sayesinde
Cambridge Üniversitesi'nde düzenlenen
İstanbul skor etkinliğine katılıp dna'yı
keşfeden Bilim insanlarından Fırat
screen dna'yı keşfettiği laboratuarı
görebilme şansı elde ettim ve o zaman
anladım ki eğer bir hayaliniz varsa ve
buna inanıyorsanız ve hatta size Bazen
küçük güzel sürprizler yapabiliyor
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde maalesef teyzemin
meme kanserine yakalandığını öğrendim
Aslında bu hikaye başta üzücü olsa da
benim kanser hastalığıyla tanışma sebep
Oldu Teyzemin klinikte alınan
sonuçlarına kendi deneysel sonuçların
hızla karşılaştırıp sürekli oluşan
sistemin nasıl ilerlediğine nerelere
vardığını sistemin tam anlamını çözmeye
çalışıyordum klinikte yaptığım staj da
bazı kanser türlerinin Aslında tespit
edilmesinin daha zor olduğunu
gözlemledim prostat kanseri de bunlardan
biriydi prostat kanseri ülkemizde ve
dünyada en sık görülen ilk üç kanser
arasında gösterilmekte yapılan
çalışmalarda prostat kanseri hastadan
alınan biyopsi örneklerinin defalarca
tekrar edilerek
bulunması sonucunda el Bu
yaptığım çalışmalarda prostat kanseri
ile ilgili Acaba ne yapabiliriz diye
düşünüp lisans eğitiminin son döneminde
bitirme tezimi Özellikle bu alanda
çalışmak istedim konuya dair biraz fikir
sahibi olmuştum Ama henüz bir şeyler
yapacak durumda değildim hemen hızlıca
yüksek lisans eğitimine başladım yüksek
lisansta elde ettiğimiz bilgilere bir
proje formatına dönüştürüp tivita sunduk
o dönem projemiz TÜBİTAK tarafından
birinciliğe layık görüldü fakat Akademi
o kadar hantal işliyordu ki bir de
yapılan çalışmalar maalesef sıradan bir
insanın hayatına hızlıca dokunamıyorum
burada bir değişim yapmamız gerekiyordu
Bu yüzden çalışmalarıma akademide değil
Özel sektörde Kendi şirketimi kurarak
devam etme kararı aldım Türkiye'de
girişimciler bunu çok iyi bilir ki
Türkiye'de girişimci olmak geceleri
rüyalar O da
ekonomistlerle sürekli ekonomi tartışmak
gibidir Çünkü doların ne olacağı
yapacağınız çalışmaların nereye varacağı
ülkenin bugünkü durumu nedir Ne olacak
bunu sürekli düşünmek zorundasınız
ardından bir gün Türkiye'de yaptığımız
çalışmaları eş zamanlı olarak Amerika'da
yapmaya karar verdik ve bu sayede
oradaki hocalarla iletişim halinde
olmaya başladık Türkiye'de yaptığımız
çalışmaları onları anlattık fakat
Türkiye'de artık hem Akademi hem Özel
sektör aynı anda yürüyemiyordu Zaten
sürekli ar-ge de para harcadığımız için
paramız bitmiş şirketimiz iflas etme
durumuna gelmişti Bir de tüm bunların
yanında Tıp hekimlerini ikna etmeye
çalışıyorduk yaptığımız çalışmanın
gerçekten Dişe dokunur bir şey olduğunu
anlatmak için Fakat o dönem çok başarılı
olamadık Ben de Amerika'daki hocaları
mla durumuk bu çıkınca bana Amerika'ya
gitmem gerektiğini Aslında bu tür
fırsatların yerinin Amerika olduğundan
bahsettiler
Ben de bu fikri ciddi ciddi
değerlendirip bir akşam aileme anlatmaya
karar verdim tam o gece Twitter'dan bir
mesaj aldım Babam prostat kanseri ile
ilgili çok zorlu bir süreçten geçiyor
bu ne yapabiliriz bilmiyorum birçok kez
bir yoksa olmasına rağmen doğru sonuca
bir türlü varamadık Artık babam biyopsi
yaptırmak istemiyor bütün umudunu bütün
hayallerini sizin geliştirdiğiniz bu
Kitab ağladığı ne yapabiliriz size ve bu
te nasıl ulaşabiliriz Bu mesaj yaz
üzerinde çok düşündüğüm bir mesaj oldu
Gerçekten ne yapabiliriz burada mı
kalmalıydık yoksa gitmek mi bizim için
daha avantajlı bunun üzerine çok
düşündüm fakat Tahsin amca bu olayı beni
çok etkiledi ve benim için çok büyük bir
kırılma anı olduğu o gün Türkiye'de
kalmaya çalışmalarımıza özveriyle
emeklerle burada devam etmemiz gerektiği
bilincini tekrar sorumluluğunu o bunun
da hissettim
ardından gazetede bazı haberler çıktı
tabii Türk bilim camiası sonradan
yaptığımız çalışmalara dikkat etmeye
başladı
piyasada ilk olarak ismimiz hiçbir zaman
tanınmadığı ben ve bayan olan ortağımla
birlikte Gittiğimiz her camiada bize
prostat kızlar diyorlardı Ayrıca basında
çıkan birçok haberde benim prostatta bir
molekül geliştirdiğim Bununla ilgili
çılgın çalışmalar yaptım bir bilim
insanı olduğumu adlı ediliyordu Hatta
sağolsunlar bana Türkiye'nin ilk kadın
ürolog ünvanını da verdiler
ne Bunlar böyle değildi bunlarla ilgili
tekzipler gönderdim ne kadarını
kaldırdılar tam olarak bilemiyorum
ardından Tabii prostat çalışmak çok ayrı
bir durumdu
toplumun çok kanayan bir yarısıyız
diyeyim sürekli espri konuları oluyordu
prostat çalışma fikrimiz yine böyle
Twitter'dan mesajlar alıyordum
erkeklerin prostatın derdi Sizi mi geldi
Siz iki tane bayansınız daha seminis
çalışmalar yapmanız gerekmiyor mu Neden
kadınlarla ilgili çalışmalar
yapıyorsunuz diye çok eleştirel
mesajlarda aldım bunun yanında çok
hoşuma giden hala unutmadım güzel
esprili bir mesaj da vardı eğer Mendel
genetiği babası İsa Siz de gene Tina
nasılsınız yürüyün gidin de diye motive
edici mesajlar da geliyordu ara ara ara
[Alkış]
mı Bu iş biraz motivasyon işi
motivasyonu kaybettiğimiz sürekli
zamanlarımız oldu dediğim gibi
Türkiye'de girişimci olmak bayan olmak
Genç olmak zaten başlı başına çok büyük
bir sorundu bu sorunları Evet bir anda
silemedik bir anda üstesinden gelemedik
ama biz kalarak bizden sonraki neslin
Aslında birazcık daha bu konuda özverili
teşvik olmasını istedik
ardından Amerika'ya gitmek fikrini
tamamen askıya aldım ve ekibimle
birlikte tekrar burada çalışmalara
kaldığımız yerden devam etmeye başladık
ardından bizi dinlemeyen bize hafife
alan Tıp camiası yaptığımız klinik
çalışmalarda testimizi geliştirdiğimiz
testin güncel yöntemleri yok su ile
karşılaştırıldığında başarısının yüzü
var Bunun üzerinde olduğunu görünce
birçok ödülle birçok örgüyle bizi
taçlandırdı lar ve tekrar o gün Anladık
ki aslında hayallerin peşinden gitmek
iyi bir şeydi tabi bu süreç yıpratıcı
bizi yoldan döndürücü bir süreçte Tabii
ki
motivasyonumuzu Tahsin amcanın mesajıyla
gelen motivasyon mesajlarıyla asla
kaybetmedik
konuşmamı özetleyecek olursam Bir
insanın bir hayalini bir hedefe
dönüştürülmesinin çok önemli olduğuna bu
hayatta kendine verebileceği en büyük
hediye olduğuna inanıyorum Her insanın
yaratılıştan gelen bir hayat misyon
olduğuna inanıyorum ve bizim başarımızın
geliştirdiğimiz yaptığımız
yapabileceğimiz her şeyin bu temel
motivasyonu doğru anlayıp bu yolda
istikrarla ilerlemekte ol bu düşünüyorum
hepimizin hayallerinin hedefleri haline
dönüşmesini diliyorum teşekkür ederim